de n'utiliser que je me tourne vers vous
avez enfin sans trahir de secret il vous
arrive parfois de fumée de cigarette est
ce qu on est choqué par parle cette
augmentation constante du prix de la
cigarette au nom de la santé publique
choquée à bien des égards je suis une
bourge suis un gros fumeur d'ailleurs
voyez ça vous prend une pilule de
nicorette pour avoir le plaisir de vous
parler sans trop chercher mes mots la
cigarette 10 euros s'opposera pas
franchement je suis capable de m'en
sortirais c'est ça pénalisera beaucoup
les gens les plus modestes
une fois de plus avec une hypocrisie
conserver 80% de ddd 10 euros iront à
l'état qui parallèlement fait des
campagnes quand une appli espèce de truc
noir nous comment dirais-je discret
discrimine le poumon tue vie et il est
fumée tue mais vivre aussi tu le dises
krivine du à tous égards
on a plus l'impression singer la
nostalgie du moment où je pouvais le
matin à paris et dans un bistrot ouvrir
le journal ou à mon café fumer ma
première club se faisait partie je crois
d'un art de vivre conviviale
malheureusement c'est un symptôme parmi
tant d'autres reculs la sociabilité dans
ce pays on en a un peu marre qu'on nous
foute la paix alcoa de santé bien sûr
c'est mauvais pour la santé je sais bien
tout sépare une demi-heure pour vous
rejoindre